this video right now what I'm saying
right this second is being watched 30
years after my death
right now this is being watched hey
everyone sorry we didn't get to meet you
were born too late get up like like you
know I'm really pissed I'm dead
[Music]
hey guy said it was a really good one in
Vegas
crikey no great podcast I really liked
it like I like the keno more than d-roc
did I told him was a special one as a
matter of fact please leave in the
comments youtube if you felt like if you
saw what I saw which is some nuanced
differences in this talk think I made
the reference indie rock I normally
throw 101 mile an hour fastball today I
threw 97 mile an hour fastball and I'm
hoping that means a couple of you can
hit it or will hit it so good day headed
back check the Cowboys tomorrow jets are
so banged up I'd like to make a
prediction that this is gonna be our
first women's ton the boys but I'm not
sure I can totally go there it'll be fun
to see in the comments what actually
happened because I'm still worried about
the offensive line in certain parts of
the receiving corps but nonetheless very
good day d-roc it's been nice women
spending some time together a lot of
time a lot of time see ya
[Music]
[Music]
they guess Saturday morning speaking mm
mortgage brokers which are really
entrepreneurs and salespeople go with a
little bit of different approach in my
mind I told T Rob that's gonna be
different
[Music]
[Applause]
and that this is important how many
people here under 35 just raise your
hands kids listen to me this is this is
not that long ago this is 1997 listen to
me this is me on a panel only 22 years
ago right when you were 13 or younger
and I'm sitting debating which is more
powerful the yellow pages or the entire
Internet and by a wide margin
I lost the debate to the 40 people
listening one nice man in his 50s was
like hey real quick so how does this
work
this is literally what he asked me I
just really want to understand what I'm
doing right now is contextualizing
everybody how far we've come to let you
understand where this is about to go and
why it's so important for you to really
get serious about this this gentleman
asked me if the way I shipped wine
through the internet was taking a bottle
from the liquor store and in the
basement there was some weird pipe I put
it in two and it went to people
I mean we were just sitting back you
know chopping it up reminiscing about
the good old days are not it happy to be
here okay good brother I've never posted
a piece of content in my family
everybody posts everything about their
family because it gets likes you're 100%
in control good don't post it okay that
works for them the [ __ ] is that to do
with you like what I do or somebody else
does or influencer does or what works
for her or him has nothing to do with
that with you if it doesn't work for you
it's gonna break anyway there's no right
way to do it there's the right way for
you to do it talk about bananas all day
I don't give a [ __ ]
you don't need to talk about your
private life I don't I don't talk about
my private life at all I meant it when I
said earlier had I not been in this
business
just the story in my life I didn't drink
any alcohol because my mom Nancy Reagan
got to my mom so alcohol and drugs like
I was clean as a whistle
if my dad wasn't in the liquor business
I know for a fact I would have never
drank alcohol in my life and I know for
a fact had I not been to the
communications business I'd be sitting
in the audience today with not a single
social media profile because I have
nothing to share with you
[Music]
you see in retrospect I would've did it
the same in hindsight I'm the only one
to blame ain't picky I'm just real
specific you're awesome thank you
brother
I'll walk with you a package this is a
personal question that was the next one
the line night I missed it it's a weird
thing I grew up there for like dirt
[ __ ] the boy yeah like nothing
yeah and so I was 16 I moved out on my
own yeah start started my life and
everyday might you know my dad would
steal work my mom was a drug addict she
overdosed she died I'm sorry and it's
part best yeah and but every day I woke
up I said I'm gonna I'm not gonna be
like right I'm gonna became your driver
I understand so but now today yeah I
have $100,000,000 appraisal company yeah
I do the appraisals forms to everybody
out there good for you
it's awesome and super successful very
company real happy but every single day
I wake up I still feel like that little
[ __ ] poor that's good I hate it
well okay so then you need to if you
hate it you need to go deeper you need
to either go into therapy I mean this is
real like you got to get the poison out
I just successful company successful
successful isn't this successful this
but I'm happy with my wife I'm happy
great kids we have a great family so are
you are you tired of having the chip on
your shoulder or is it deeper than that
I'm just having the chip on Russia yeah
I mean look I think the question becomes
you I believe
here's what I believe and I could be
wrong I believe and you can't do this to
your wife or others this is why I
believe in therapy or some other version
or some other version if you have a
stigma on that here's what I believe I
believe people don't realize by actually
saying something out loud and getting
the poison out I believe there's three
to four things that are deeply inside of
you they
never said it all that are completely
predicated on Mohammed I nameks that a
second they come out of your [ __ ]
mouth whether on Instagram video to the
world because you're like [ __ ] and I'm
gonna tear this whole thing down or yep
or by going and sitting with somebody in
a private room or however the [ __ ] you
for going to a [ __ ] forest by
yourself and screaming it at the top of
your lungs I don't care how you do it I
promise you without knowing all the
details there's poison in you that
you've never said out loud I'm just
saying this was hard I could see it yeah
brother
what there nobody's gonna judge you on
that like like this is why I always tell
people put out all their [ __ ]
skeletons cuz that's the [ __ ] jail
there's no amount of money and success
you're gonna make that's gonna fix that
you got to get the poison out yeah you
gotta get the [ __ ] now yeah got it
thank you get the poison out bro thank
you I mean it how I'm telling you
something of course it's real yeah it's
real it's what it is
thank you the success doesn't cover it
yeah it's not it's it's not the outside
if the inside and what's scary is just
getting it out of your mouth I've
watched so many [ __ ] people win that
game but it's hard
the reason it's still broke the reason
it's still in there it's good it's hard
if it's so easy and say right now you
always think getting successful make it
go away yeah well yeah because people
think the outside fixes it it's the
inside
[Music]
so as a working mother yes it's very
difficult very prioritize everything yes
and I have a very crazy passion to grow
my business I have I by people like
Humpty and small I want to grow rapidly
but that's right bang that like that I
tried it no no rapidly yeah rapidly is
the problem the reason the reason you
have friction the reason you have a
question right now is being a working
mother having crazy ambition and being a
mother should eliminate and has to
eliminate the concept of rapidly and
this is where everybody gets caught you
don't realize that this is what I you
know I talk about this I know you watch
my content you don't know how young you
are
I get it but you're wrong
yeah you're not I feel like 15 years of
grind I've been doing and I tried
through social media I tried doing like
oh I got a real job like hey you yeah I
mean it'll gets broken up better they'll
give me their hardest and deduction for
like hardest transactions nobody else
Kenya and they'll take away the business
so how do i improve it like dude I did
not like come on bye bye communicating
into the world and by being patient 15
years is not as long as you think
it's not everyone's like no I want to be
an entrepreneur like you I'm like I can
we started at six
she lemonade shoveling snow washing cars
like truly at six I'm 37 years in um I
actually it's funny I brought it up
today which I don't do often which is
like van 43 year old needs a lot better
than 22 year old me you know 22 year old
me was a natural talent and it's funny
when I listen to all time great athletes
you know I listen to like Kobe LeBrons
and they talk about that like they talk
about like I'm 33 now there's certain
things I can't do but there's so much
more I can you up 35 40 more years it's
the word rapidly when it came out of
your mouth is the TEL it's like poker
it's when I know that you're in trouble
you need to slow it down
got alertness that's right
practice I think the biggest thing is
about relationship with time and when
you have ambition let me at Chris really
is you know it's why I keep looking at
him like his ambition what he's trying
to achieve is a big deal it really
matters
again I reference it at the top of the
list of the things that I get private
message about
the men and women that service our
country till I keep us safe that are
dealing with the mental health issues
they're dealing with it's a big one but
he'll he'll fail if he tries to go too
fast or tries to boil the ocean it's too
big I want to change everyone's lives if
I even think about that I'll fail I just
got to do what I can and then when I'm
98 92 113 whenever it's a rap I gotta be
like look I left it on the field what we
all have though is we now can have
legacy because of wouldn't a call and be
rocking up and drew are doing like like
I caught this video right now what I'm
saying right this second is being
watched 30 years after my death right
now this is being watched
hey everyone sorry we didn't get the
feed you were born too late you know but
like you know I'm really pissed I'm dead
but but that's real yeah like that's
real so slow it down
I think that those are the two things
that matter I think there is upfront I
think about things and extremes and
finding balance with them them so you
know using technology communicate at
scale makes sense I'm gonna I'm probably
on the way to the airport now in Vegas
make a video and I'm gonna press a
button in my community app which is a
new text messaging app that I'm in the
alpha or beta of and it's gonna text
125,000 people in one shot I'm not
sending it one by one however as soon as
that goes out a bunch of people gonna be
like is this really you or they're gonna
say something about the content I said
and then I'm gonna go one and one and be
like Neil it's me like it really was me
I sent this or Sally no your issue with
thought process or with Facebook
strategy or with management is this so I
I love scale but I think that
non-scalable is the equal dancing
partner to it and I believe people think
it's one or the other so I'm more of the
mindset of 5149 non-scalable
because I do think that human variable
is the decision maker in a service
business I want to make a positive
impact on the world it's very important
to me a gratitude of the circumstances
and the parenting that I was given my
way of doing that is not how everybody
tells me to do it which is go fight on
Twitter my way is to instill things like
gratitude and empathy and kindness and
patience that's how I plan on doing it
I'm not worried about boiling the ocean
one day at a time one day at a time one
day at a time and then you wake up forty
years later you've created a legacy
I think we should take this off first
maybe they'll get something funny by
accident
how are you sir real pleasure
[Music]
real pleasure to take care be sure I
still see 526 yeah keep going
you